[Musique]
monsieur mais grimm avez vous été
diagnostiqué schizophrène il ya dix ans
je veux vivre une vie normale
c'est tout ce que je veux qu'est ce qui
est normal et qu'est ce qu'il n'est pas
annie pourquoi tu es là
suivent dépression
et ça dure depuis pas mal de temps
j'ai confiance en ce traitement et je
pense que nous pouvons tous être guéri
j'ai besoin d'être guidé ses options non
je trouve pas ça débile
j'ai trouvé
ou est-ce vous qui devient croisé mon
chemin
à chaque fois que je laissais part il
trouve le moyen de se rejoindre il se
peut que ces deux là qu'une connexion
cosmique
on était juste deux êtres
qui vaille est l'un sur l'autre
[Musique]
où
on attrape plus de mouches avec du miel
qu avec du vinaigre et donc je suis le
boute-en-train
je raconte une histoire les gens ne s'en
lasse jamais parce qu'ils s'identifient
à eux mêmes à ce genre d'histoire je
suppose et nous aimons entendre parler
de nous tant que les personnages qu'on
retrouve dans ces histoires sont
mais pas nous celle là sera décisive
[Musique]
je suis buster basters kraft tout six
coups et charger
[Musique]
apparemment oui
tu as quelque chose à dire avant que la
sentence soit exécutée la sentence mais
quelle sentence à aa
[Musique]
ici dans le grand ouest la situation
peut vite dégénérer
au nom des ozymandias wade roi
ce type est vraiment sûr pas pareil a
plus qu'à chercher tu crois pas
ces milliers de malades
[Musique]
première fois
il tout le monde est du même avis on
veut que vous soyez le commande
vous aller sur la lune le premier homme
sur la lune
ça va être un sacré voyage
tu es sûr c'est une aventure moment
christian riché ton père va aller sur la
lune notre mission est si difficile
elle exige un tel niveau d'avancées
technologiques qui va falloir repartir
de zéro
bah dis donc c'est une belle bête ça va
être une vraie bombe atomique si ça
explose
il on a eu un problème le module n'est
pas assez sûr
il est vivant j'suis pas sûr de pouvoir
tenir très longtemps
c'est pas facile à dire
ils sont morts neil il faut qu'on échoue
ici si on veut pas jouer là haut à quel
prix c'est un peu tard pour se poser la
question
neil c'est peut-être la dernière fois
que les garçons tout va est ce que
quelqu'un a coûté aux suisses tout
ficelé blake
tu crois que tu vas revenir à la maison
on a bien l'intention de revenir de
cette mission mais c'est pas sûr
[Musique]
décollage
on a un gros problème
on contrôle la situation
rien du tout
il accuse kiev pape
[Musique]
là tu ne m'as pas sergent 1 et sort de
l'un
[Musique]
dis moi tu es de virginie malabar tle
est-ce que brandon est là
il est sorti et je fais juste le suivi
de quelques points sur la dernière
affectation de brandon
est ce que votre fils a déjà mentionné
le nom de daniel murphy
écoutez monsieur quoi que vous vendiez
on en fait quoi je ne suis pas du tout
un recruteur madame martel où il avait
déjà eu une fois vous n'allez peut
reprendre d'ouvrir merci de l'édition us
pourquoi on va bien sûr l'autre promets
moi que tu prendra bien soin
ouais évidemment il à partir de
maintenant vous devez me promettre de
faire ce que je vous ai bien sûr serge à
me surpasser de merde y'a pas bien sûr
clic et vous faites ce que je dis je
prends ce fou tu as une idée de ce
qu'ils veulent il doit être division des
enquêtes criminelles ces [ __ ] font
tuer certains des nôtres alors on va
tuer certains des leurs cette foire
d'automne
qu'est ce qui s'est passé là jeanne
accusent l'armée de rien du tout je veux
juste savoir où est mon fils bien sur le
court
je peux compter sur vous pas vrai oui je
veux pas que tout ça fasse partie de
murder on est seul à souffrir des sceaux
craque on garde
brendon bon temps c'est fait vous pensé
des dieux en gardant le silence
il est plus que temps je t'ai situe
celle ses habitants ne seront plus
mais si ça devait arriver je voudrais
d'abord d'entendre de ta bouche
[Musique]
vous m'aviez dit que vous vouliez
entendre d'abord de ma bouche
alors je t'écoute
[Musique]
avant tout ce que je voulais c'était
devenir adulte
mais aujourd'hui je vois le monde tel
qu'il est
bonjour
on en revient
tout ce qu'on aime peut disparaître
d'une seconde à l'autre
je suis catherine choc police criminelle
tu pourras connaître ses hommes
oui
ceux qui ont fait ça avant tout faire
pour te retrouver
maintenant ils savent que dd tu as une
idée de ce que ça veut dire
apportez moi je peux dimitri avait pour
nous et alors je pourrai protéger sa
fille
[Musique]
nous sommes en train de vivre l'une des
plus grandes révolutions que l'europe
ait jamais connu c'est une simple vérité
on a tous une peur bleue de rouge
tavannes toning bientôt avec les nazis
ça va être à nous de payer pour être
occupés pardon monsieur vernal vous ne
pensez pas que la venue défendre
banker listed tu as perdu la raison
on n'est pas des résistants oui on est
des banquiers c'est tout je n'ai pas
envie de mettre en danger et mis les
enfants
moi aussi j'ai une famille toi aussi tu
es dans le coup je vois pas de quoi tu
parles
c'est la nouvelle mode
afone mobile est officieuse quand même
pas cambriolé la banque du pays bas on
n'a pas d'autre choix
vous n'avez pas la moindre idée de ce
qu'on a vécu nous avons payé pour tous
la résistance des groupes armés les
unités l'espionnage les unités de
sabotage
absolument tout
[Musique]
quoi tu veux qu'on arrête pas question
j'ai pas envie qui t'arrive quelque
chose
agassi
bonjour kristin davis merci d'avoir
accepté de me rencontrer lui pas mon
propos est de décrire de la manière la
plus honnête qui soit le travail d'un
représentant de l'ordre
le jeu du pendu avec deux mannequins qui
font partir la 125 ses numéros de votre
a signé notre numéro s'équilibraient
vous n'êtes plus de la maison c'est toi
qui es parti ok j'ai pris ma retraite
tu m'a supplié de revenir et j'ai
accepté autres suspects veut qu'on joue
au pendu avec lui pour l'instant on à
teneur trop mais on a trois lettres ce
qui veut dire qu'on n'a pas encore
trouvé la première victime
envoyez-nous la scientifique je crois
que notre homme veut qu'on aille draguer
leur hymne hier le borough à l'intention
de tuer une proie à 23 heures précises
et ce à toutes les 24 heures je suis
intervenu parce que tu poursuis un
fantôme je veux que toutes les unités
disponibles y aille en renfort exécution
leïla
cent vingt minutes je suis légaliste
wartel la vie d'avant le jeu est
vraiment l'enjeu il faut fermer la mine
maintenant oui moi plus qu'un geste
[Musique]
vous voulez entrer un stanford
oui j'ai vu de très bons résultats à mes
évaluations donc vous êtes bons élèves
est-ce qu'on peut écrire je comprends
pas à part étudiante
hélène comme lui avale un vrai
tempérament artistique vous avez s'y
rapporte us weekly
toi tu es la plus sublime des créatures
[Musique]
ça jamais lu l'impression que monde
entier et rejette comme s'il te disais
que tu le veuilles ou les avait pas vus
je me demande comment survit quand on
allait voir les poutres de la fraude
veronica est prononcé dans le seigneur
des anneaux tu voulais parler de
quasimodo le bossu de notre dame
je voulais dire par là que te regarde et
me donne envie de m'arracher les yeux et
qui toi
j'ai rencontré quelqu'un on s'est
expliqué c'est très clair qu'il me prend
pour quelqu'un d'autre c'est de
l'usurpation d'identité c'est totalement
illégal
non mais je rêve veronica veronica et je
vais être en concurrence avec elle sur
les milliards des numéros qu'il ya dans
le monde il est tombé sur l'avenir tu as
quand même besoin d'être réglo ces mémos
c'est à moi qui veux parler fait plus
qu'un beau gosse du football r non parce
que tu le trouve beau gosse
non est ce que ça te dirait de sortir
avec moi je sais que tu as donné mon
numéro à des mecs au hasard et alors
alors je crois qu'on peut peut-être
s'entraider mais je te demande un petit
service
t'es sûr que ça va marcher non je suis
sûr de rien je suis très très content
c'est le salut
tu as passé une bonne journée c'est
bizarre le son de ta voix est légèrement
décalé on ferait mieux de remettre ça un
soir où ça fonctionne ouais bien sûr
j'arrive je crois petit pourrait craquer
sur moi tu corresponds totalement tu es
mon genre ouais
est-ce que tu as une idée de l'enfer et
s'est battu son nez de l'étrave dans la
peau d'une fille aux belges
c'est ce qui est le plus dur qu'on se
sent affreusement minérale
[Musique]
je lui dois la vérité je me sens pas
prévu
je sais pas qui tu es je te reconnais
je reconnais tu as beau
vous la connaissez pas super coup comme
si la terrifiante candia moi je sais pas
kg
[Musique]
normal pour celles et ceux qui ne
connaissent pas je suis le docteur birch
et j'enseigne la philosophie du langage
et vous êtes encore des mots d'amour et
blanc bonnet quand je vois de quoi s qui
parle d'une jeune fille disparue près du
lac le merch oui entre marie et de la
maison de quoi s'agit-il
dans une fille de ce field on a eu le
signalement d'un homme à bord d'une
volvo grise en train de surveiller les
jeunes filles le jour de sa disparition
voulez-vous me dire où vous étiez savait
difficile a du mal à me souvenir de ce
que j'ai fait ce même dernier c'était le
dernier jour de zelda au camp des sétois
qui est passée la prendre yann moix la
monitrice a dit qu'elle avait attendu
avec votre vie pendant 40 minutes en
retard c'est un crime de nos jours ren
est évident entre avoué je ne vous dirai
plus rien savoir d'abord mon avocat
vous avez l'habitude d'affaires comme
celle ci quoi vous parler d'enlèvement
ou bien vous parlez meurtre avez vous
rencontré joyce bonheur je crois pas
quand quelqu'un disparaît ici les flics
ont besoin d'un suspect la coïncidence
vos amis dans leur viseur mais ces types
ne pose pas de questions il pose des
mines pas la berge
nous avons trouvé une mèche de cheveux
bruns coincé dans la banquette arrière
de sa voiture
qu'est ce qu'il faisait dans tout futur
[Musique]
c'est son rouge à lèvres zelda la
trouver sur moi comme monte qui monte
sans arrêt ce bonheur est quelque part
est si elle est toujours en vie la
pauvre jeune fille est en sursis
la philosophie nous avons le même but la
recherche de la vérité
ça vous arrive parfois d'avoir des trous
de mémoire lieutenant très bonne
question
la qualité ne serait qu'une illusion est
ce que je dis la vérité ou est ce que je
dis ce que j'ai perçu que tu as préféré
garder ça secret à moi ta femme
de te calmer puis patrick
ce qui m'effraie le plus c'est de savoir
de quoi d'autre tu arrives à te
convaincre enfin tu me connais tu sais
que je serai pas de mal à une mouche
vous partez à l'eau
et vous revenez tout de suite
pas de visites guidées n est pas que des
cessions
seigneur fais de moi un instrument de ta
paix
là où sont les ténèbres
je met la lumière
la wii la toule union c'est bien pour ça
que je voulais à interdire cette
connerie d'expédition pour éviter des
morts inutiles
c'était pas inutile restons calmes
je suis chargé protéger tout le monde et
c'est moi qui décide quand même là où
est la tristesse que j'avais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au seigneur
je cherche
à comprendre ça prouve que son cerveau
fonctionne
il évolue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ton mot maman
khoury suicide à l'éternel puis